[Music]
hey what is up guys umhd here and
welcome back to another video in the
tesla model s video series the one
that's shot entirely on smartphones this
one's being shot on cameras only from
iphone 8 8 plus and iphone 10. it's all
the same sensors on the back but the
front facing camera stuff will be from
iphone 10. i like the idea of including
the front-facing camera in these more
often because number one people like to
see what the selfie camera looks like
and number two so you can hear the audio
quality that's something we also have to
talk about in smartphone video cameras i
might also do a video in this series
with the google pixel 2 since i said
that's a great smartphone camera but for
now again all iphone here and this is
about the tesla wrap so the most basic
question that i had before i did this
but that you may also have as well is uh
why would you wrap a car in the first
place why even do that that's a good
question and there's a couple
valid good answers to that question so
the thing about living in the northeast
of the united states is the roads are
not that nice uh lots of lots of gravel
potholes rock chips a lot of salt in the
winter time
so to protect their cars a lot of people
put what's called a clear bra on the
front of the car where most of the
damage happens so it's like a hardened
layer on the front of the car protects
the paint underneath but looks like
there's nothing there because it's clear
a full body wrap on the other hand uh is
more used for like restyling or
completely changing
changing the paint color you've seen
what i've done with dbrand skins on
phones it's like that but a much larger
surface of the whole car
so you can do that to change the color
of the car but that will also still add
a little bit of a layer of protection to
the paint underneath you can take it off
whenever you want but it was those two
things that put me over the edge to
deciding to get
my car wrapped most people don't get it
wrapped after 25 000 miles they usually
do it like right when they get the car
but uh yeah that's what we're doing so
that takes us to new york
when i'm on the rails
i go to two
i go to two
i go to
when i'm on a
[Music]
i'm on that train
i got my passengers going insane
fire fire
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but the
[Music]
that's what it looks like when it's done
i personally am really happy with it i'm
glad i did it you call it a bit of a
space gray that we ended up going with
technically the color is 3m
satin dark gray but with the black
on the chrome parts it kind of has this
sort of a sleek under the radar space
gray look i think that's pretty sick
there's only a couple specific things to
keep in mind when wrapping this exact
type of car number one is like i showed
the door handles
that is a specific part that you can
wrap all the way down to the body which
is really cool second is if you have
autopilot version 2 hardware there's
cameras right here don't put a wrap over
that and there's also cameras up here i
didn't wrap this part but don't wrap
that either that will actually interfere
with the autopilot hardware
but i didn't do that anyway and another
minor thing is this big chrome piece
here if you wrap the entire thing then
folding and unfolding the mirrors a lot
might scrape the top so you can disable
folding mirrors and settings i did that
just to keep it pristine so either way
that is it that is what a space gray
tesla model s looks like
i think apollo is kind of a perfect name
for it now that we've seen the final
result shout out to matt from phenomenal
vinyl i'll link their stuff below they
do great work and obviously it turned
out awesome so if you're ever in new
york and you're doing a car wrap check
them out
and uh shout out to tesla for making
great cars also let me know what you
guys think of the video quality this has
been split between iphone 10 and iphone
8 plus but i'm gonna let you guys know
in a little monika at the bottom of
which stuff is shot with which phone
it's all been at 4k 30 fps i think it
looks pretty darn good
either way
talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]